[Applause]
[Music]
Rex it's like a rabbit hole have you
ever been reading a Wikipedia article
which leads you to another article and
then another and another and you know
six hours later you're reading about the
digestive system of a giraffe wondering
how you got there what brexit is
something similar in fact the media has
been talking about so many details of
brexit that the very word has become an
everyday verb saying goodbye to everyone
at a party and then proceeding to stick
around the big questions we have are why
is the UK still a part of the European
Union why have they been arguing for
such a long time and what are they
arguing about now you might not have
noticed but London and Brussels have
been negotiating for more than three
years now and there is still no end in
sight
even now there is still a possibility
that the UK might have another
referendum and remain an EU member
[Music]
so questions for today are well what are
they arguing about why is the UK still
in EU who is to blame for all of this
bracket mess taking so long should we
blame Brussels or London off just nobody
in particular while today we're going to
answer all of these questions but before
we do let's take a look back at the
history
the impossible deal on the 23rd of June
2016 the United Kingdom called a
referendum with a clear question should
the United Kingdom remain a member of
the European Union or leave the European
Union 51 point eight percent of the
voters said leave many people think a
1.8 percent difference is not enough to
make such a drastic decision others say
that it's democracy in action but the
truth is from a strictly legal point of
view brexit could be easier than it
looks
[Music]
to make a comparison the Catalonian
separatists in Spain pose a real
challenge to the law why because the
Spanish Constitution does not recognize
the right to self-determination and this
is why no one knows what to do that
however in this case the UK doesn't have
a constitution so technically speaking
everything is possible as long as
Parliament votes in favor of it and EU
legislation does recognize the right to
leave the Union there you have it a
member state may decide to withdraw from
the Union in accordance with its own
constitutional requirements Treaty of
the European Union article 50 in other
words if they had wanted the UK could
have already left the European Union
they do not need a deal at least from a
legal perspective the problem this would
be an economic disaster with no special
deal the UK would trade with the
European Union under the common rules of
the World Trade Organization this means
a lot of border controls and especially
tariffs many of you might say well so
what Australia has the same tariffs with
Europe and they're doing pretty well and
well yeah of course they are the thing
is that Australia and Europe don't
really trade that much with each other
but half of the UK's exports they go to
Europe if we suddenly put tariffs on all
of those products most of the UK
companies would suffer and some would go
bankrupt and the same would happen with
some EU companies but not only that the
European Union itself would have a hard
time why well mainly because of its
budget
[Music]
you see many EU budgets are not approved
for one specific yet for example the
agricultural budget which is one of the
most important covers six years of
policy this means that in the year 2014
brussels negotiated a budget that will
last until 2020 back then in 2014 the UK
was a member of the union and also one
of its main contributors if they want to
leave now the EU says while all right
dude I'm okay with you leaving but he
did already commit to paying millions
and millions of pounds and while I made
my calculations based on that money so
you gotta keep paying this is what we
call the brexit bill that's the amount
of money that the UK must pay in
compensation
[Music]
but make no mistake this has not been
the biggest point of disagreements we're
gonna get to that later what you need to
understand now is that both the EU and
the UK want a deal the question is what
kind of deal and here is the problem the
brexit referendum left a very polarized
British society a country divided
between brexit ears and remain 'as the
first victim of this was the Prime
Minister himself who was just in case
you forgot a man named David Cameron
Cameron organized the referendum but he
personally voted to remain and well how
can you successfully negotiate a way out
if you wanted to stay in there was a
clear sign that he had to resign so
instead of calling for elections he made
a primary vote within his own party the
Conservative Party also known as the
Tories and the winner was this one Rhys
amazes brexit means brexit and there
will be no attempt to remain inside the
EU and as we always say here on visual
politic as it was said so it was done as
soon as mrs. May put her souls on
Downing Street floor she activated
article 50 London then had two years to
reach a deal with Brussels and leave the
Union at this moment everything was
going as planned but then May wanted to
secure Parliament's support Paul
suggested she could reach a bigger
conservative majority so in June of 2017
she called for elections and well this
was the results
[Music]
Teresa may losses overall majority in UK
Parliament's yes you had that right
Teresa mais plan completely backfired
she failed so much that in order to be
in the government she had to reach a
deal with a minority party the DUP so
who are the DUP what are they stand for
well we'll come to that later but for
now just remember their name because
it's very important the thing is with a
less conservative Parliament mrs. Mae
went to Brussels to start the
negotiations a few days later she
returned with a deal the EU was happy
with the conditions and Mae was happy
too she just had to get one last thing
Parliament's approval and well what do
you think happens did they pass it well
the result was a historic defeat for Mae
almost nobody voted in favor of her deal
even half of her own party said no to
her and so now you may be wondering well
why what was so wrong with Mae's plan in
order to understand we must tell you a
story about tomatoes and yes I did say
tomatoes so let's just get into the
story shall we
[Music]
[Applause]
soft breads it's versus hard breaks its
if you thought all tomatoes were created
equal you better think again
we have transgenic tomatoes and
non-transgenic Tomatoes Europe for
better or worse has very strict
regulations against GMOs now we don't
really want to get into the debate of
whether GMOs are good or bad here but
the truth is all EU member countries
have the same anti GMO regulations
thanks to this a Spanish farmer can sell
his tomatoes in Germany Belgium the
Czech Republic or or every wants without
any problem nobody's afraid that a
Spanish tomorrow is going to be GMO
because nobody in the EU sells GMOs
[Music]
all right so far so good but here is the
political problem Argentina has softer
regulations with regards to GMOs so
let's say Spain wants to make a trade
deal with Argentina so they can buy
tomatoes from them all of a sudden this
Spanish farmer could barley GMOs from
Argentina and that would mean that since
Spain is in the European market this
Spanish farm I could sell GMOs in
Germany Belgium and the Czech Republic
[Music]
as you can imagine the other countries
would not be happy with this this is why
the EU member country means that you are
restricted when making deals with other
countries but hold on a minute because
we're not done yet
there are many European countries that
don't belong to the European Union but
have special deals with Brussels for
example Norway Iceland or Liechtenstein
are not EU members but can sell freely
to Europe Norwegian salmon is sold and
everywhere from France to Poland's to
give you an example so what does this
mean for the Norwegian government well
it means that even though they are out
of the EU they must follow the same
regulations as a member this is the
price they have to pay for having access
to one of these world's biggest markets
and here is where the problem starts for
the UK what may suggest it was very
similar to what Norway has this is what
we call a soft
brexit it basically means well alright
we don't want to be in the EU anymore
but we're still gonna play by your rules
bracelet is essentially said that is not
happening we voted wrecks it because we
don't want to follow the rules of
Brussels okay all right so what are the
true brexit ears once well they want
what they call a hard brexit
this means that the United Kingdom
doesn't play by Brussels as rules and
therefore they can do trade deals with
whoever they want does this mean that
they wouldn't be able to sell tomatoes
to Europe as easily as they used to well
yes of course they would have to add
lots of customs controls but this is the
price for being really out of the Union
and of course the tomatoes were just an
example to understand the situation
better a harbour exit would have a lots
of consequences for other products as
you can imagine machines cars food you
name it but the question now is well why
don't they go for a hard break sit then
I mean what's the problem there okay so
you see if the UK was just one island
there'd be no problem at all but the UK
has 136 inhabited island and a problem
can be found on one of them in
particular Ireland some of you might not
be aware of this but Northern Ireland is
also part of the UK and Northern Ireland
has a land border with the Republic of
Ireland's which is not a part of the UK
okay so now you might be thinking well
what's the problem with that assignment
can't you just put customs controls at
the Irish border
where's the problem in order to
understand this we're gonna speak a
little bit about the cranberries and
YouTube yeah we're going to talk about
music and it's very very dark history
[Music]
Sunday Bloody Sunday if you like music
or YouTube you surely know one of their
most famous songs Sunday Bloody Sunday
if you don't like you too maybe you like
the cranberries and their greater zombie
what these two songs have in common is
that they both talked about the Northern
Irish conflict also known as the
troubles you see this region had two
opposing paramilitary organizations the
IRA or the Irish Republican Army who
were Catholic and left-wing and they
wanted Northern Ireland to be a part of
the Republic of Ireland's the Ulster
loyalist paramilitary forces who were
Protestant and a right-wing wanted
Northern Ireland to stay as part of the
UK
we're talking about a conflict that
lasted for more than 30 years and left
more than 3,500 casualties a total
bloodbath that affected several
generations if you want to understand
the magnitude of this conflict there are
a lot of movies and a lot of songs that
portrayed the troubles but this all came
to an end in 1998 when the British Prime
Minister Tony Blair reached the famous
Good Friday agreements basically in this
deal the two sides of the fight agreed
that Northern Ireland would be British
but the Irish border would remain as a
soft border meaning that everybody could
cross it and buy and sell goods without
any problem
now thousands of people cross their
border every single day a heart breaks
it would mean breaking this Good Friday
Agreement and no one wants to do that
because it took decades and a bloodbath
to get there but not only that after the
Good Friday Agreement the violent groups
decided to lay down their arms and turn
their fight into a political battle
since then
IRA supporters went to shin vain and
Ulster loyalists went to the DUP
remember I told you about the DP some
minutes ago well these are those guys
today the DUP is a very conservative
party that opposes gay marriage and has
extreme nationalist feelings towards the
UK
they also have 10 MPs in Parliament who
supported mace government as you can
imagine the deal between May and the DUP
was extremely controversial don't forget
that some of their members had been
linked to a violent group but you know
that politics is sometimes complicated
so why do I want to highlight the DUP
particularly
[Music]
Dangerous Liaisons after failing with
the first deal Teresa may return to
Brussels in order to negotiate another
but I let's be honest here her deal was
pretty much still a soft brexit so when
she came back to London the MPs they
said no again and well what did to
reason they do she thought should try
again sure back to Brussels made some
minor changes and came back to London
with pretty much the exact same deal
even her own party were pissed off with
her it looks like she was playing games
and even the Speaker of the House of
Commons took drastic measures John
Bercow rules out third meaningful votes
on same deal basically this is the
British way of saying all right Teresa
may [ __ ] you've tried it once
stop trying this [ __ ] again okay by this
time may had to ask Brussels for an
extension because she couldn't get
support in London so in the summer of
2019 she resigned and again the
Conservative Party made primary
elections to choose a brand new prime
minister and the winner was the man you
see on screen now getting ready to come
out on October 31st come what may
do-or-die come what may Boris Johnson
prime minister of the UK basically
Johnson's plan was a hard brexit this
means he wanted hard waters with customs
controls and all of that hard stuff all
about Northern Ireland's well he came up
with a very creative solution basically
he wanted to turn it into a special
economic zone so Northern Ireland could
trade with the Republic of Ireland
without any problem just the way they
had done before but trade between
Northern Ireland's and the rest of the
UK would have to pass through some
customs controls in fact this idea could
have been a good boost for the Northern
Irish economy they could have become a
sort of brand new Gibraltar Brussels was
really happy with the deal I mean just
look at this clip and tell me it's not
beautiful
I have job clothes the boss yeah yeah I
have I have to say that I'm happy about
a deal but I'm set about back seat have
a good time yes Johnson's deal was
signed in a friendly mood and good old
Boris thought everyone in London would
clap had done it it finally solved the
brexit puzzle Oh Boris Johnson is so
smart we love you let's go get a beer
except swell no that's not what happens
[Music]
you keep Parliament just blew up Boris
Johnson's breaks at planets yes yes it
seems British politicians are hard to
impress but let's see the bright side of
the story now Johnson was way closer to
reaching a majority than Theresa May to
start with most of the Tories backed his
deal so why did he lose who was the big
surprise here and yes well you
absolutely guessed it it was those 10
MPs from the DUP who turns their back on
Johnson's plan but why
[Music]
why didn't they like it well think about
it the dup are diehard British
nationalists and the idea of Northern
Ireland having a special status which
makes them virtually closer to the
Republic of Ireland sounded like hell to
them and this is when Boris Johnson did
the maths and he said okay so what do I
need to do to get Parliament's approval
on my brexit plan well I just need 16
more Tory MPs just 16 more hmm hey guys
what does the electoral survey say I
call for a general election could I get
16 extra MPs that I need ah okay good
there's our general election shall we at
the time of making this video we still
don't have the outcomes for this
election but so far survey say that
Boris's bet may be successful
the DUP might not even get seats in
parliament and the Conservatives are
gaining more and more traction but we
also know that surveys are not exactly
accurate so well now the question goes
over to you what outcome do you expect
it do you want as hard a brexit as soon
as possible or would you like the UK to
have a second referendum do you think
Boris Johnson will succeed in his plan
well please leave your answers in the
comment section below and before
finishing this video I'd like to give
special thanks to Karim halal who helped
just with the research for this video
also please visit our friends from
reconsider Mediacom the podcast that
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine as always don't forget we
publish brand new videos just like this
one every week so please do subscribe to
this channel hit that Bell button so you
don't miss any of our posts and if you
liked it give it a thumbs up and I'll
see you next time if you want to learn
more about politics and world affairs
and here's some more of my lovely voice
come check out the reconsidered podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider @ww re consider mediacom
or on Apple or Google Play or your
favorite podcast
[Music]